die hinweise auf einen auf eine
terroristische vereinigung in einer
terroristischen vereinigung angehört die
haben wir nicht
wahrscheinlich wird alles abgeklopft
selbstverständlich wird auch abgeklopft
auch da haben wir noch keine hinweise
derzeit ob es möglicherweise weitere
personen gibt die eine rolle gespielt
haben könnten
wir haben keine hinweise darauf derzeit
aber selbstverständlich werden wir dort
durch die beamten des polizeilichen
staatsschutzes und die
generalstaatsanwaltschaft das
ermittlungsverfahren führt
selbstverständlich jedes detail
abklopfen und die in stein umdrehen
ja das kann ich ihnen jetzt nicht sagen
nur ist 30 jahre alt irakischer
staatsangehöriger in bagdad geboren und
er hat 1 0 und status weiter details wie
lange er hier ist und wo genau kann ich
ihnen jetzt nicht
soll sich entsprechend vor ort geäußert
haben ich selbst verhalten und
entsprechende allahu akhbar äußerungen
haben sich ganz konkrete hinweise darauf
ergeben dass hier ein religiös
islamistischen hintergrund zugrunde
liegen könnte
dazu kann ich ihnen jetzt nicht sagen es
gibt die haben derzeit keine
erkenntnisse dass der weitere personen
rolle gespielt haben könnten aber
selbstverständlich werden wir das umfeld
des mannes abklären da gibt es durchaus
die vermutungen dass entsprechende
kontakte gibt das muss man
konkretisieren da kann ich ihnen zum
gegenwart noch nicht zu sagen
da werden wir genau im einzelfall
abknöpfen